Remember that Web site memberships are the
primary way we fund the David Pakman show.
Grab a membership at Join Pakman dot com.
We're going to discuss how Corona virus cases
are once again exploding nationally, hitting
records in 13 states.
But before we do that, in that context, we
have to talk about a Cauvin positive Republican
senator, not just a senator who doesn't think
Cauvin is a threat.
Understand?
But this is a guy who has corona virus was
at the first day of hearings for Amy Koni,
Barratt's nomination to the Supreme Court,
speaking with no mask.
I'm talking about the Utah Republican senator,
Mike Lee.
Mike Lee was one of these three senators who
tested positive in Trump's orbit last week
or so, along with North Carolina's Thom Tillis
and Wisconsin's Senator Ron Johnson.
So Mike Lee tested positive for coronavirus
wearing no mask yesterday at the hearings
while speaking.
So in this first picture, if you're watching,
you see Mike Lee on your left with a mask.
The mask is not fully covering his nose.
Next to Lindsey Graham and right above the
head of 87 year old Senator Chuck Grassley,
Mike Lee has coronavirus.
He tested positive 10 days ago.
He's there for some reason.
Speaking over the head of an 87 year old.
All right, then during the hearing here is
recently covered positive.
Mike Lee speaking with no mask on in an enclosed
room.
Stunning stuff right now.
Some of you will say, oh, well, he's probably
not contagious anymore.
Is that the defense?
He probably isn't contagious because it's
been 10 days.
He's in a room full of old people having tested
positive 10 days ago with no mask wide chance
it.
Why not just keep the mask on?
Because you tested positive 10 days ago.
They don't care.
And even when wearing the mask, it's not a
license to be on top of people.
He's on top of 87 year old Chuck Grassley,
who, by the way, also doesn't seem to care
too much about the threat of coronavirus.
Of course, that's his problem if it's of his
own doing.
But understand what Mike Lee is currently
doing in the United States Senate, which is
he's at a large gathering in a confined indoor
space without a mask after testing positive
for covert 19.
That's illegal in a lot of countries, even
in many states.
I mean, in Oregon and Matthew, you're not
allowed to do what he's doing.
It wouldn't be allowed you wouldn't be allowed
in a grocery store in Canada with what Mike
Lee is doing.
And he's in the U.S. Senate, around nearly
90 year old men.
I hear a lot of comments like these guys are
pricks.
That's a term maybe when someone cuts cuts
you off in line at the supermarket, somebody
takes the parking spot you're waiting for
and had your blinker pointing to.
Maybe that's a prick.
Okay.
This is a guy who tested positive for a corona
virus, speaking without a mask in a room with
people nearly 90 years of age.
It's monstrous.
It's almost bio terrorism.
Now, everybody, calm down.
I'm not saying it is bioterrorism, but it
is almost bioterrorism.
He's choosing to endanger others.
He could have Skype it in, as some senators
did.
He could have at least kept the mask on the
entire time, as other people did.
He could reduce the risk of transmission by
keeping the mask on because remember, he tested
positive for coronavirus.
This is not the vague.
Well, you know, maybe I'm asymptomatic and
don't know.
He tested positive for the virus.
But again, Trump is starting rallies.
Trump had a rally last night with people crowded
together.
Even the people on the stage behind Trump
weren't all wearing masks.
At another one of these super spreader events.
So look at the examples that are being set.
Mike Lee setting an example for the people
at Trump's rally, the people at Trump's rallies,
setting examples for what people Republicans
in the Senate are doing.
It's a complete and total mess.
And by the way, and this is what we'll talk
about next.
The virus is surging again.
And let's go right into the numbers.
I